[Music]
we're gonna be covering today a couple
different points I'm gonna walk you
through the loyalty history of DFW it's
been an important part of our brand in
our business for quite some time and
then why jump into the asking needs what
the business came to us to do on how we
were going to move their loyalty program
forward from there I'll turn it over to
cam my lead engineer here we'll talk us
through the choice on how we landed on
the Google cloud as well as our
implementation so what our lifecycle was
getting into the cloud what it's doing
for us and how we're him and his
development team how they're able to
deliver on a day-to-day basis and then
at the end I'll come back in and follow
up with what it looks like today how
we're implemented how we're moving
forward and kind of what's next for us
as DSW and designer brands so the
history of loyalty again EF stuffy has
been around for quite some time
originally just a brick and mortar
retailer like most others I mean the
loyalty act program actually started
back then so in late 90s they actually
launched the first loyalty program it
was called reward your Stiles was
actually sourced and supported outside
of DSW in 2004 we brought that in-house
and then quickly thereafter in 2006 we
actually launched DSW rewards
d/f subby rewards as you can see from
the timeline there while it launched in
2006 really didn't have much change or
impact to it until we launched VIP just
this past September we did implement
over the course of time there the
experience on our comm profile we didn't
implement that in 2009 but when we did
that that was a customer's choice so we
still had people that could have a calm
presence but not be part of our loyalty
and it added that confusion to what
they're ultimately doing you had people
that thought they were in loyalty people
that didn't think they were in loyalty
so in 2013 when we rebranded and
re-platform Darkon profile we enrolled
everyone into the profile so when you go
to DSW comm or if you give us an email
in your story you're instantly into our
loyalty program now to unify that across
the board I won't spend too much time in
the last part cuz that's the big meat of
how we got into VIP key thing to talk
about though from this solution that
they had even once we brought it
in-house from the original program was
there was no dedicated team to support
it so if they
needed data in you know they'd call
somebody that whoever they knew in our
integrations team if they needed
something modeled they'd go with our bi
team to change the the internal data
model for them so they just kind of got
in queue they had no priority no
emphasis on things so they would get
creative they would start doing their
own workarounds doing things and coming
the ITT later say hey you have to do
this because we've already told our
customers we're doing this which would
obviously create a lot of stir and
priorities prioritization changes on the
IT side we'd have data fixes adjust
we've got redone in a vacuum that we
then live through as we're trying to
implement and move from an on-prem
database to a cloud database all those
fixes had to become reality and new life
in our world so what the asking needs
for the new loyalty program so we did
while this is DSW program we honestly
view this as our customers program so we
went out we surveyed we asked the
customers what are they looking for what
do you want to do what is DSW mean to
you and what are you looking for in our
loyalty program so there was kind of
some key things that came out of that
that really rope up into these these
four points real-time everything so we
lived in a batch based world where you
know transactions came in on a nightly
sales screen they were processing
processed through and we would notify
hey maybe you earned a reward or maybe
you earned a new tier but you don't get
that reward till seven days later and
we've already lost that engagement we've
lost that opportunity to reconnect with
that customer so we want to make sure we
can give them in their points give them
their tiers communicate not just via
email we want to implement and get more
into SMS and app push notifications make
sure that customer recognizes you've
transacted with us
re-engage with us move this forward keep
DSW in the front of their mind
flexibility so the customers wanted more
ways to interact with us we were a
points-based based on sales transactions
we wanted to be able to you know give us
your data give us an interaction given
this point you're in a store donate
shoes other things they wanted to do
outside of just a sales based
interactive program and from a marketing
standpoint they wanted to flexibility to
be able to move quickly in their old
world they would take up to two to three
weeks to set up a new promotion and it
was an xml-based hit the weight on
batches overnight where now we can react
in two to three hours we can have a new
promotion set up and moving for them a
simplified program before the points
were 10
ten points for $1 or 20 or 25 or 30
based on where you were at what
promotions run so people would walk out
the store not knowing did I even get the
right amount of points what happened
call it a call center extra touch points
and just confusion to what they
ultimately were trying to do and then
all the way as we looked at all those
points we needed more data to know about
our customers we want to make it more
personalized more engaging more
opportunities to make that experience
their very own so that kind of came in
on the back end along with I t's need to
align the marketing's needs so as I
mentioned previously there wasn't a team
to support that came and I helped make
up that team now we'll get into a little
bit more later but we recognize that as
a need if we're really going to jump
into this and deliver what the business
really needs we need to then in turn
give them a team that they can come to
and out when we drive them in line with
their visions so with that I'll turn
over to cam and kind of talk us through
our new loyalty and how we got there
cool somebody's camp Island I'm the tech
lead for analyst or marketing
applications team a little bit about
myself I'm from Columbus Ohio
engage get married in June I have a huge
wedding that you can tell really excited
about it and then pretty much my kid
it's my dog Romeo he's either really
happy or just really sassy all the time
which was pretty much me throughout the
project so like I was really engaged
really happy at the beginning and then
like halfway through I'm probably
napping at everybody and then at the end
I'm really happy again the big thing
here is I do understand that I have two
pictures of my dog and one picture of my
fiance that was just kind of put the
point of like the project was a little
tough if I did the same pictures of my
fiancee it probably won't work out very
well well I got home yeah let's get into
this a little bit from a history
perspective we landed out we had two
databases that sat on pram so we had one
analytics database we had one real-time
database so for the real-time database
we had soap based interactions that were
you know become pretty inflexible as
you're moving forward and we were just
continually building on tech debt
essentially so every team had just their
own operations so we're stuck with like
90 operations that pretty much did the
same thing over and over again which
becomes a challenge
but these just really did just you know
get your customer information update
your customer information and get your
points pretty simplistic stuff that we
knew we couldn't use moving forward the
other pieces of this it's just that you
know operations it's kind of a nightmare
if we want to integrate with third
parties that's going to be a couple
months because we have to do from a
security perspective we're just mostly
going off of you know firewall rules
things like that that take you know two
to three months with our existing
infrastructure so not something we
wanted to build upon the second piece of
this is that we just had XML files going
down every night or every month or every
week sorry every week that would change
to about every day to do points give
rewards give tears we've kind of lost
the customer engagement at that point
also a lot of operations just a lot of
like pinprick things so we have to deal
with that we just didn't want to deal
with moving forward the last piece of
this is we had analytics database people
would just run huge queries trying to do
models it would tear it down break it in
the middle of night people have to wake
up just a challenge you know we have to
scale we had to move towards that so
we're starting to do that so we had
three options here one option is we
could just keep building it on Prem yeah
with the things we wanted to do that
clearly wasn't what we could do we could
buy it off the shelf but it then at some
point you know where other customers are
using this other other companies are
using this so we're no we're not really
different than them so we decided to
move to the cloud we decided to partner
with slalem and they were huge and
helping us really change our mindset in
architecture and just helping us build
this moving forward so the challenge
ahead of us was is that we didn't have a
lot of cloud experience very in our
infancy we had a couple applications out
there but nothing huge like Louis he was
going to be but also like rich talked
about there was no central person or
team they don't this so it's all tribal
knowledge you know be going meeting to
meeting finding out something different
but at some point we landed on a couple
of things so we just had to move forward
and go so we did that but then we got to
a requirements like the worst
requirement you can ever deal with which
is all current features and
functionality must be infinite in the
new system that's just kind of like you
open up a box and everything's shaken up
and you have no idea what's going on
so but we were like pretty eager I'm a
millennial so I just kind of jump in and
think I'm gonna live forever so
so we just kind of jumped into it got
excited but we wanted to build a
community not necessarily just a little
tea platform we wanted to build a
community this is what we wanted to
build it on so we wanted to be API first
wanted to enable anything that's in
loyalty to be outside facing that we can
interact with our customers not just our
regular customers but also third parties
you know anyone wants to connect to our
platform the second piece this is B
developer centric so no manual deploys
you don't have to wake up a like to deal
with things you know we're gonna reheat
ourselves and also we're just going to
name a lot of automation and even
third-party integrations you know the
biggest piece of moving to the cloud
like Evan will talk about just the
flexibility scalability mount stability
and that's the biggest thing was just
you know application analytics for us we
can't have our real-time database or
real-time databases real-time
applications getting impacted by models
so we got to break that apart and figure
out how we're going to scale then the
last thing just real-time analytics so
the big thing that we dealt with is that
you know we wanted to stream data all
the time in the old system but we have
an on-premise server that has a bunch of
licenses we don't want to buy more
licenses so we're only going to take the
data that we can take and that's gonna
hinder our analytics as we're moving
forward because we're not getting
everything we're just getting pieces of
it so how should we build loyalty right
that's the biggest piece we need to
build the platform first and keep moving
forward we need to monitor eyes that as
well so what we did is we jumped in
kubernetes I mean just like everyone's
talking about we use spring Roo Java
services whether that was synchronous or
asynchronous communication so API or
event-driven we're gonna do that to
essentially enable our platforms so it
can scale to the traffic and the
customers that we're gonna have so we
ended up creating you know seven to nine
micro services if you want to talk about
technical details I'm going to say
pretty high level here so we can talk
after or hit up the dory but we need to
make sure that we could scale moving
forward you know we have a pretty small
team especially starting off and so
dealing with a bunch of operations
that's just not going to work for us but
yeah so to 10 micro services a couple
that really handle most of our api's
just because of just how loads he's
working right now
but then the rest were really
adventuring and it could scale up scale
down pretty easily the biggest thing in
your Hill your you know
you will hear every retailer talk about
is you have a bunch of servers for like
two months of the year because that's
when all the customers coming to you
that's when everyone's coming to you
kind of saying hey we need this right
now we need to shop we need to buy
everything last minute that's kind of
what happens but you've got servers
sitting there for the rest of the year
and they have licenses you got to pay
for all that keep the lights on for it
so we want to make sure we're using what
we can use and using it when we need it
when customers are coming to us once
their parties are coming to us things
like that
all right cool we got a load to platform
it can scale it's gonna it can interact
pretty easily but how do we secure ApS
right everyone talks about security you
need to have it but we need to enable
that pretty easily so we move to Apogee
and I've used Abbott you previously so
this is a pretty simple decision using
this as our gateway and able a lot of
the easy security features for us also
enabled a lot of third-party
integrations so being able to spin up a
developer portal pretty easily you know
putting animals out there allowing
people to just see it interact with it
ask for an API key ask for off easy to
interact with you know good for us as
we're moving forward and we're building
this developer community and the biggest
piece that we really didn't know about
that really helped us moving forward is
the payload transformation I'll talk
about this a little later I want to
talks about implementation but we have a
decent amount of legacy systems and we
couldn't change it there's legacy
systems so that was a huge pain as we
got into things but we got around it
made things work and Apogee was huge in
that sorry how are we going to enable
analytics honestly really simple
decision I'll show you our pattern after
this move to bigquery you know we can
easily scale everything there's hardly
any operations data storage is cheap and
we're able to do you know query
petabytes of data and you know 30
seconds if we optimize it maybe 15
seconds as we're moving forward and
create whatever models we want to for
our analytics team yeah and it's pretty
easy decisions like i blank out on
accessories thesis and how do we go how
do we get information into the system
out of the system this is the last piece
you know we've got our AP is an API
enablement we've got a loyalty platform
have all our our data warehouse so cool
we've got everything how do we stream
how do we get data and this is pretty
common for us again it's all huge with
this pretty simple process drop a file
into a bucket cloud functions you know
kick off and kick off a dataflow job and
then you know spin up a service
architecture but right - right - cloud
sequel right to bigquery pretty pretty
simple decisions we continue to do this
as we're also interacting with our API
so streaming streaming based jobs enable
us to really anything we we add to our
cloud sequel database or any new API we
add we can just kind of update our
objects common it'll pick it up as we
redeploy the job and boom we can stream
everything to any of our tables so and
then the last piece was how do we enable
developers you know we could have easily
built loyalty and just said here's
loyalty but we're gonna hurt ourselves
moving forward so we need to enable
developers because you know there were
so many times that we were waiting on
resources for two to three weeks it's
not anyone's fault it's just like yeah
you got to get servers or you got to get
licenses or you gotta get whatever so
the biggest thing that's going to the
cloud is that you can kind of get over
it all that and and not have to deal
with any of it so the biggest piece we
use zip for extras code which should be
terraformed so terraform allowed us to
just do pull requests and have uniform
environments uniform naming standards
everyone can see everything but we can
build out whatever we need is the time
at which we need it so as we're moving
forward you know we can get you know new
pub subs we can get a new database we
can get whatever we need in a fresh from
an hour versus a week so it's great for
us then the last piece is just the CSE D
we're still working on this a little bit
but this was pretty simple water of just
using pit bucket storing our code and
every time something goes mid-market
Jenkins kicks off pushes pushes a bit
out there we're good to go ready to
checks blue greens so we don't have to
deal with anything in the middle of the
day we can deploy at any point in time
and not have to worry about doing this
overnight and pretty simple pretty easy
stuff to do with with Jenkins so this is
where it gets tricky so we had
everything that we wanted to have we're
really excited about it and then you
know a couple months down the road
we've reloaded the database about 30
times change the schema about 60 times
and we're all pretty frustrated just
have to deal with
how implementation goes you know I
wouldn't say it's you know learning the
new cloud platform its yeah there's a
little bit of a challenge just a little
bit of mindset change but the biggest
thing is moving all your existing
challenges and problems and getting rid
of those and moving to the cloud you can
easily you know if you want to spit up a
machine put your stuff on a machine
that's pretty easy we didn't want to do
that we wanted to you know set ourselves
up for the future I'm gonna keep moving
there so we get an implementation we're
going into every meeting and that that
that requirement of you know everything
existing has to stay the same just kills
us every single time you know we're
coming in have a new feature about every
other meeting and we're probably six
months down the road at this point and
you know we're doing with all these
hidden requirements so whether it's tech
debt with logic built-in api's logic
built and stored procedures those api's
are calling just the network latency and
it's not the clouds latency it was our
latency that we did we didn't want to
admit to at times but that was a big
challenge and the other challenges that
we just weren't really set up you know
you're never gonna be ready when you're
moving like straight to the cloud you
just kind of got to do it you're gonna
have the challenges there's going to be
pain points but just do it it's going to
be worth it in the future
but you're gonna have to deal with it
and then just the last one it's
integrating with legacy applications
whether it was JSON XML you know people
are looking for these certain fields
there's a bunch of transformations and
the api's that aren't real at the
database we dealt with it all we deal
with those problems and it really the
biggest problem was just day-to-day data
you know we didn't necessarily know what
our data was and that's just because of
the tech tech we built up over years so
we get through it all we're starting to
get you know we're starting to get some
steam and we get about three weeks out
like man we just totally forgot about
this piece we didn't have any dashboard
set up we weren't sure what we needed
from an alert standpoint but you know
luckily like this is like my one pitch
to go it's like stackdriver it was
awesome you know it easily integrates
with everything else you're gonna do so
whether it's latency api's with Google
endpoints alerts dashboards you name it
it's got it
it was awesome for us really easy to set
up and we could just have everything
overnight and and we still use it today
pretty awesome
also just with error reporting huge for
us for bug visibility we could figure
out you know who made this call at this
time
what operation died at that point what
was the issue so you know we get to the
last like three weeks and you know we've
been out probably yeah I did I know I
did something like 7:00 a.m. or 7:00
a.m. to 2 a.m. shifts so it's like kind
of tough at that point but luckily
everything actually went pretty fall
asleep uncut one not punched but we had
a couple of scares you know going into
the night to go live probably the best
story is the the one day we actually
were about to go live and we had to call
it off because our points were messed up
and then Kevin and Tim brought us a cake
that day forego life it felt great but
that was one of the funny stories
I think couple days later we actually do
go live but yeah you can look back and
laugh at it back that now but yeah but
yeah we were alive and honestly we were
so close to Black Friday it was a little
bit of a concern for sure but honestly
we had a lot of peace of mind moving to
the cloud you know with everything we
had had we were killing all of our
performance numbers without actually
like optimizing everything so we hit a
ton of numbers that we wouldn't have hit
in previous programs you know things
that would would go down during peak
times
we're easily scaling up and we had no
problems at all
you know Black Friday time we were
hitting numbers we hit numbers that
we've never had before which were huge
for us and awesome but you know what
I'll say is is that with going to the
cloud you know Google's been great
partners song awesome partners but
moving to the cloud itself it's just
peace of mind at some point you know for
us with a team that's pretty small I'd
have to do what the operations have to
deal with everything I had to come from
on-prem world where I'd be up in the
middle of the night like I I don't have
to worry anymore at this point you know
I know things are going to scale up I
know things are gonna retail themselves
and everything's a lot easier moving
forward especially even building new
features everything's a lot easier
because I don't have to worry about my
resources I don't have to worry about
what I need to develop the tools
move our program forward so here's what
we did you know this is what we started
with we weren't 100% sure we're like
this is really a lot of the tools that
we thought we needed but we didn't need
these tools to move forward and this is
what we ended with the biggest piece of
this is you know we're continuing to add
new features every day I seen data
fusion cloud run which looks awesome for
us but things got things are getting a
lot easier and were able to either get
these really quickly you know if we
would have went with a third party
essentially just someone we bought off
the shelf if we bought it on Prem
there's no way we would have made it in
a year's time to actually deploy this
thing there were so many changes that we
had to do not just not because of you
know bad architecture but it was what we
knew at the time but we were able to
change easily throughout time and
continually change as we're moving
forward on the platform so I'm gonna
give this to rich now if you have any
questions you know feel free to catch me
after feel free to ask the dory thank
you thanks cam so yeah we're kind of
talking through where we're at today
office obviously enabling this platform
for all of our marketing partners or
analytics partners to really drive this
forward so just some quick stats and
where we're at since we've launched
again this was September 25th a day that
will forever be stuck in my mind some
different some quick numbers we've done
one that we're very proud of is that top
one up there in the corner
rated number one most innovative loyalty
program by Shopify something obviously
we pat ourselves on the back about but
realize now that we've launched this and
we're out there we have to keep that
going we've reached the top very quickly
we appreciate that a lot of things went
into that and now you know obviously we
want to stay there can't mention this we
went quick close to holiday so think
about that's two months prior to Black
Friday this past Black Friday we hit
some of the highest sales know the
highest sales numbers on an hourly basis
that DSW has ever seen and that number
speaks for itself absolutely zero issues
on our platform we were going through
holiday readiness plans and like who's
gonna be on site who's gonna do this and
we're like we're gonna Henry support
this remote or well sleep in if you call
us need us zero phone calls the other
thing as we moved into the cloud and
again we were went from an environment
that didn't move very quickly we
done since go live over 900 enhancements
and bug fixes to our platform that kind
of goes the big pat on the back for our
friends assalam helping us move to that
agile platform as well as what the cloud
has given us from a deliverability
standpoint to continuously improve and
move upon what's out there another big
one was our again trying to stay in
contact with our customers to do mobile
pushes from the app in notifications
based on previous system limitations we
had to break our audience into eight
different groups and slowly send it out
make sure it's sent make sure we didn't
kill the network through performance
testing as we led up to through the
holidays we got that down to one big
group of people and these like oh great
we're gonna send it and we looked at
brought up stack driver monitoring the
logs okay there was the blip and we're
done and it wasn't even if you had to
zoom in and find the blip like it really
hit did you guys actually do this we
find 100 percent fine ongoing
opportunities so obviously we're out
there we're alive moving through it as
cam mentioned I mentioned we have a very
small team so it's the continuous growth
of our engineers we have only a couple
in we have a couple on our team
individually we have a strong contractor
base again partnered with slalom has
been ongoing but we just need to
continue growing them we're new to the
cloud we understand it but this platform
and our partnership with Google has
allowed us to continuously growth and
understand that the sky's the limit from
where we want to go internally as a team
Kim hit on this as well our DevOps so we
had DevOps as a dia sub your
organization for the own Primm platforms
that we had but now we're talking cloud
DevOps that means something different to
them when they're asking ok how your
backups gonna be handled how you know
when you're passing on a handle what are
your schedule for that we're like I
don't know what's called Google let's
find out like we didn't have to worry
about that we had our guys focusing what
was important and that was delivering
those 900-plus fixes on going day after
day by the way if you do the math that's
like five per day business days that
we've deployed since then so pretty
staggering numbers but it's getting that
DevOps site up to speed because we know
we're going to continue to develop on
and on and on and we need to make sure
that back-end is handled incidents are
properly addressed data as things are
there so I can keep the people like cam
developing the front end things that are
important to us in alongside of that
Cystic a ssin so obviously we've been
living and breathing
Google cloud for over a year now working
very part very close with Kevin and team
getting out there but groups like our
audit team our security team our
database admins you know how can we
perform this so what can we do for them
again we don't need you to do that but
here's how you help us here's how you
can help us move forward to keep DSW
moving in the right direction team
challenges so we were very proud we've
built this real-time application that
performs it scales it does everything we
needed to do but we still live in a
batch based world so every night we
still take snapshots get it down to our
own prime database we still have to get
that data down to third parties we're
still working through those legacy
systems and legacy applications to make
sure they're whole but it makes it you
know difficult they're like okay we sent
the data down to edw last night can you
run a query to validate that yes I can I
go to bigquery I can use all my data
dates but our application is built to
know what are you doing in the moment
for that historical for that real-time
snapshot project tech debt so timeline
compromises things led to you know we
just can't get this done in the timeline
we need to there were some analytics
things in either some data things they
needed were like we'll get to that but
we had a deadline we needed to meet but
via the agile process using JIRA using
the process we have we know we can just
recover from that we're not going to
build ourself a 12 year tech debt that
we absorbed as we took on this project
and that kind of leads into the last one
so our backlog is out there we know what
it is had to work through but now we've
enabled a process for our marketing
partners to realize that they can get
stuff as quickly as they can almost ask
for it so we went live in September just
here in the next couple weeks we have
another pretty big release coming out we
already have another one scheduled for
the fall as well so as I'm looking
through that trying to make sure that we
are being sure we prioritize to not to
dig through our backlog make sure our
tech debt doesn't get up there as well
as we're making sure that we can support
the business for their ongoing
opportunities as I mentioned to start
with they really didn't have a marketing
team or an IT team to support our
marketing partners so as this came along
again my team was stood up and I brought
on people like cam and other folks to
give our DSW marketing partners not just
one team to deal with the designer
brands marketing IT team but obviously
we have a great partnership with a
Google cloud
and our partners at slalom as well help
us really build from what was a very
disjointed process to a collaborative
group that continued moving this forward
solemn came in again day one of our
project really helped us build out that
architecture that came and walk you
through but they it wasn't a you know go
lives done we're out they're still there
they're stopping us build our strategy
making sure that as we're looking for we
what we have done and what we're doing
forward we're not putting ourselves into
a hole and they've been a great
partnership it's been even though
they're based out of Atlanta were based
out of a Columbus we'd even see that as
a problem you know the interaction and
communication we never caught them off
guard and they never caught us off guard
it didn't growth so as Kevin mentioned
to start with when we launched this and
started going into it we were DSW Inc
since then we just recently rebranded
ourselves and as a parent company we're
designer brands Inc what that really
means is we we as a IT shared services
support all these brands now so DFW VIP
is live for the u.s. we have DSW Canada
so we're in the process of launching
moving them over to the cloud and using
our same loyalty platform for our
Canadian based stores Shuko and shoe
warehouse have a loyalty program also
based in Canada that were in the process
again rewriting that moving it to the
cloud they quickly saw the the benefits
that we had and implemented for our
us-based stores and asked not can we
have it it's can I get it tomorrow they
understand what kind of value were
driving to keep their program moving we
also have the commuter group and our
affiliated business groups that you know
typically their company ok can you do
this can you guys handle this
you know cam and I are sitting there
going you know essentially bring it on
give me more people to help do it
because we need it to happen but the
cloud has given us a platform that we
don't have to say no to anymore
analytics team we can enable them you
know the data is theirs they're not
asking us to remodel anything you know
here's a big query you go after it if
you need more stuff we'll get it to you
but we can get it to you quick and cam
kinda hit on this as well and it's kind
of like our thing that we've realized as
we've gone through the whole process is
there was no shortcut to getting to the
cloud we want to make sure we did it
right but since we've gone live we've
recognized fully that it's 100% worth it
like we know looking no no looking back
no questions did we do the right thing
did we not do the right thing
it's been since literally the first time
we started streaming data into and we're
like okay that data was bad we have to
redo it it was quick to fix it quick to
move forward and just recognize the the
benefits of the data stores the
opportunities the data flows that we've
used um our friends that saw him can
confess for it how many times we asked
him to pivot and change but the cloud
gave us that capabilities the
infrastructure scales everything that
they're helped us out and again that
growth slide that we just talked to
limits where we're going and what we're
going to do for designer brands as a
whole
[Music]